إيدي ، كيف حالك ، أنا بخير كيف
حالك أولاً وقبل كل شيء تهانينا ، لقد كان
الأداء والكيمياء
بينك وبين جيسيكا استثنائيًا
للغاية وبالطبع مشهد العشاء
هو المفضل لدي ، أخبرنا المزيد عنه ،
هل تعلم أن مشهد الديناصورات  كان الأمر
غير عادي لأنه في هذا المشهد
، تم توصيل شخصية إيمي بشخصية جيسيكا تشاستين ،
وهي موصولة بالميكروفونات والتنصت
عليها وبالطبع في الحياة الواقعية كانت سلكية ، لذلك
لدينا كل هذا
التسجيل وتم التقاط الكثير من هذا المشهد
حرفيًا كما تعلمون من قبل
كاتب السيناريو كريستي ويلسون كيرنز
لذا كان من غير العادي معرفة
الحقيقة ومعرفة كيف كان هذا المشهد جزءًا لا يتجزأ من الحقيقة
، ولكن أيضًا
كتبه كريستي بشكل مذهل عن
حقيقة أنه عندما
تعمل مقابل شخص مثل جيسيكا
تشاستين الذي أعتقد أنه واحد  من
العظماء الأحياء والوصول إلى المنتجع الصحي
وتحدي بعضهم البعض
في مثل هذه البيئة الحميمة أه
فيها شخصيتان تحاولان الرؤية
وراء قناع بعضهما البعض
هذا هو نوع الأشياء التي
يحلم بها الممثلون
لأنها لا تحب الطيور ولا يمكنني التغلب على
مدى روعة فانيسا
[موسيقى]
يا إلهي ،
يوجد الأنسولين في نظامها
[موسيقى] ،
لذا فهذه قصة حقيقية وحقيقية  القاتل المتسلسل ،
كيف دخلت إلى الشخصية ، لذا
تستند هذه القصة إلى كتاب
يسمى الخير والسيناريو هو
الثلث الأخير من هذا الكتاب
، والثلثان الآخران عبارة عن
سيرة ذاتية معقدة وحميمة لحياة تشارلز كولين
الرجل الذي لعبت دوره  وهو
كتاب غير خيالي ، لذا فهو عبارة عن
تقارير نفسية ، فأنت تعرف آراء
أصدقاء الزملاء ، ولذا
كان هذا الكتاب المقدس بالنسبة لي حقًا ، ولكن بعد ذلك
كان الأمر يتعلق بالعمل مع مدرب مذهل
لللهجة ، رجل يدعى مايكل
باستر ونحن  العمل باستخدام تسجيلات
تشارلي للحصول على درجة
صوته بشكل صحيح ، وبعد
ذلك تم وصف هذه الجسدية الفريدة التي يمتلكها بأنه
يشبه علامة استفهام نعم ومم
، وفي نظرية كل شيء أعمل
مع هذه المرأة التي تدعى أليكس  أندرا
رينولدز ، وهي راقصة
وهي تعمل قليلاً على إيجاد ذلك ، لذا
تبدأ نوعاً ما بكل الأشياء الفنية
ولكن علي أن أفعل ذلك
قبل شهور من أجل ذلك بحلول
الوقت الذي تلعب فيه أمام جيسيكا جميعًا
من هذا قد انتهى أو آمل أن يكون جزءًا
منك في مكان ما ، وأنت تلعب
أمامها فقط بعد مشاهدة هذا الفيلم
يجعلني لا أرغب في الذهاب
إلى المستشفى ، وهذا يجعلني خائفًا للغاية
خاصة عند رؤية الممرضات ولكن دعنا
نتحدث عن تدريب الممرضات
ربما يجب أن أقوم بتصوير هذا الفيلم
بشكل جيد وسيكون من الواضح تمامًا
أن صنع هذا الفيلم جعلني
أحظى باحترام كبير للممرضات
كما تقول مثل جيسيكا وقد
تم إرسالنا إلى مدرسة التمريض
لبضعة أسابيع وهذا فقط  زاد من
احترامي للممرضات أن تكون ممرضة جيدة ،
يجب أن تكون
قويًا من الناحية الفكرية في العلوم والرياضيات ، يجب أن
تكون قويًا جسديًا مثل
تحريك الأجسام الفعلي كان شيئًا أملكه
يجب عليك أيضًا أن تكون متعاطفًا بشكل لا يصدق
وقادرًا عاطفيًا على أن تكون
هذه القناة بين الأطباء
والعائلات في أضعف حالاتهم ،
بحيث تكون عادةً ما تحصل على
رواتب منخفضة للغاية ، وبالتالي
فإن خروجك من نهاية الوباء بشكل خاص جعلني
أحترم  الممرضات فقط تعلم أنه كان من
خلال السقف بصراحة
[موسيقى]
تسعة
الآن كان المستشفى قد فعل
شيئًا كنت تعتقده لذا نعم هل
تتذكر العمل مع شخص يدعى
تشارلي كولين
نعم
كانت هناك شائعة عنه أنهم وجدوا
الأنسولين ورجل ميت يبحر
كيف تشعر عندما تبحث
عن اسمك أو اسم الفيلم على
Google وترى الكثير من
الانتقادات تتنبأ حقًا أنه سيكون لديك
فرصة كبيرة جدًا في موسم الجوائز ، ما
هو شعورك حيال هذا التقدير
أم ماذا؟  حاول ألا تبحث عن
اسمي بشكل عام لأن هذا
أمر مروع وعادة ما
ينطوي على الكثير من الصدمات ولكنني فعلت
ذلك نيابة عنك
جيدًا أه هناك  كيمياء في صناعة الأفلام ،
لكن عندما تقرأ نصًا ، يمكن أن
يكون لديك غريزة ، لكنها تمر عبر
هذه الآلة الاستثنائية من
إبداعات الكثير من آراء الناس
ورؤى مختلفة
، وهذا كل ما أعتقده دائمًا أنه
سحر عندما يجتمع الفيلم معًا
بنجاح  آه بطريقة
تجعلني أشعر بالفخر لكوني جزءًا منه عندما أشاهد الفيلم
وأشعر بذلك لأنه غالبًا ما يحدث أن هذا
لا يحدث ، فأنت تعلم ذلك عندما يكون
هناك صدى حول فيلم  أو عندما
كنا محظوظين جدًا بهذا الفيلم
الذي تعرفه من خلال Netflix ،
شاهده الكثير من الأشخاص عندما
يتصل بالجمهور ، إنه شعور رائع
بصراحة
وأه على وجه الخصوص أشعر
أنه نوع مما وجدته مثيرًا
للاهتمام  الممرضات الجيدات لم يتناسب مع
أي صندوق كان من ناحية أه
أنت تعرف قصة بطل إيمي لوكرين
ومن ناحية أخرى ترى أن هذا
ربما يكون أكثر سفاح متسلسل غزيرًا
في التاريخ ولكنه أيضًا ليس ضروريًا  ily
الشرير الوحيد الذي لديك أيضًا قصة
عن نظام مكسور وفي
جوهرها قصة علاقة وأنا
أحب أنها لم تتناسب تمامًا مع
أي نوع من أنواع الصناديق ،
لذا نعم ، حقيقة أن الناس قد
استجابوا لها هي  شيء رائع
يا إيدي ، لقد سمعته تمامًا
وأشكرك كثيرًا على الوقت الذي
قضيته في الإجابة على أسئلتي ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك
يا رفاق.